it is time to decide once and for all
which is the better system Microsoft's
brand-new Xbox one that just came out or
1996's Nintendo 64 let's take a look at
the facts the Xbox one costs five
hundred dollars and that's just the
system then you gotta buy a second
controller Xbox Live a game or two it
adds up the Nintendo 64 is cheaper and
significantly more available what are
you getting for that money these days
gaming consoles are for more than just
gaming they have to also play movies
Xbox one support sites like Netflix and
Hulu but the Nintendo 64 can barely
handle the cutscenes in Resident Evil 2
but the real reason you buy a console is
the games and the games available at
launch are critical to a platform
success the Xbox one launch with a
variety of titles like Battlefield 4
Forza 5 and something dance 2k14 the
Nintendo 64 only launched with two
titles but one of them was called Mario
64 let's take a look at what's going on
underneath the hood now the Nintendo 64
comes with four whole megabytes of RAM
and keep in mind that you can upgrade
that to eight if you buy Donkey Kong
Country
unfortunately the Xbox one is eight
gigabytes of RAM which is actually over
1,000 times more and yet despite all
that hardware you can still watch this
entire video in the time it takes the
Xbox one to load a game of madden and
then there's the wild card categories
like I don't know does your console
monitor you and your loved ones through
its all-seeing eye through the Kinect
the Xbox one keeps track of you your
voice and what your skeleton is shaped
like I'll let you decide if that's
creepy but maybe the most important
question of all is does it play
Goldeneye and we tried for a while with
the Xbox one but we just could not get
it to work but did it play in the
Nintendo 64 goddamn right it did winner
and still the best thing of all time
Nintendo 64
and now the video is over cuz we're all
just gonna go play Goldeneye